bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la sécheresse qui
frappe le pays des sols craquelle les
agriculteurs souffrent 18 départements
sont déjà en situation d'alerté les
récolte estivale s'annonce
catastrophique énième signal du
dérèglement climatique comment répondre
face à l'urgence et faut-il changer nos
modèles agricoles face à l'ô de plus en
plus rare c'est notre grand débat dans
un instant avec nos invités qui se cache
derrière les mercenaires ultraviolents
de wagner deux grands témoins ce soir
qui tout comprendre de la milice russe
la plus secrète du monde qui sévit
actuellement en ukraine et dans beaucoup
de pays d'afrique elles ont réalisé un
film exceptionnel toujours en replay sur
le site de france télévisions wagner
l'armée de l'ombre de poutine sénia
bolshakova et alexandra rousset sont
avec nous ce soir enfin nous
retrouverons nos a franchi pour leur
parti-pris elsa monde à gabat et son
carnet de campagne quotidien sur les
législatives le regard de joseph macé
scaron sur le départ de jean castex
péter ce soir à matignon et puis la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand trade
inspiré par le film encore de cédric
klapisch ciel diaby l'allégorie de ce
que nous traversons voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs revoilà donc la
sécheresse et son lot de conséquences
dramatiques surtout dans un contexte de
crise alimentaire et si la planification
écologique si présente dans la
présidentielle on la faisait vraiment
bon soir noël mamère bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau écologistes
ancien maire de bègles ancien député
europe ecologie les verts ici même à
l'assemblée soutien de la nuque donc
voilà nos pêches la coalition de gauche
emmenée par jean luc mélenchon meilleur
score des écologistes à la
présidentielle ever jamais battu je ne
m'en réjouis pas un jour est posée sur
un meilleur score j'allais oublier et
oui plus que jusqu'à monsieur jadot
qu'est ce que c'est un exado bons
parents on a le meilleur sur ce plateau
bossoirs gaspard madness bienvenue vous
êtes maraîchers porte parole de la
confédération paysanne ile de france
bonsoir dominique alors pardonnez moi
alias ducharme dominique chargé il va
nous rejoindre dans un instant bonsoir
et bienvenue vous êtes hydro
climatologues qu'est ce que ça veut dire
précisément hydro climatologues ça veut
dire que je suis chercheuse sur les
liens entre l'hydrologie terrestre et le
climat donc notamment comment le
changement climatique influence les
ressources en eau vous allez dire ça
vous être très précieuse ce soir parce
qu'on va s'interroger sur nos modèles
agricoles de demain on a l'impression
qu'il va falloir les échanges et
directrice de recherche au cnrs à
distance avec nous ce soir joël limouzin
bonsoir vous êtes vice-président de la
fnsea depuis la vendée merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes chargé des situations
d'urgence à la fnsea et vous êtes vous
mêmes agriculteurs et je précise que
dominique chargé président de la
coopération agricole lui même
agriculteur en loire atlantique va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
voilà pour les présentations on plante
le décor si j'ose dire avec vous pour
commencer comme chaque soir si j'ai bien
compris stéphane blakowski
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sens riam bonsoir à
toutes et à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir j'ai bien compris myriam on va
finir par détester les belles journées
ensoleillées pourtant cet hiver mais tu
es contente tout ce beau temps regarder
à nice a battu des records
d'ensoleillement n'y avait jamais eu
autant de journées de soleil bomba sauf
qu'il a en deux mois plus tard on a vu
les conséquences puisque il a fallu
alors que le printemps n'était même pas
encore commencé déclenché un plan d'
alerte sur la sécheresse dans les
alpes-maritimes la sécheresse qui ne
touche pas que le sud de la france et
donc la vie talent il ya dix-huit
départements où il ya déjà des mesures
plus ou moins forte de restriction d'eau
alors que on n'est pas encore en été
donc c'est tout à fait inhabituel il a
regardé on a l'impression que le nord de
la france est plutôt épargné or ce matin
à la une de la voix du nord
de quoi on parlait bah oui de la
sécheresse même dans le nord on attend
la paix lors pour bien se rendre compte
je vous montre un agriculteur du pas de
calais qui me montre que bas la terre
est devenue un peu dur comme du caillou
donc voilà vraiment ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
sécheresse ce qui nous amène à faire ou
on arrive à une terre qu'on ne peut plus
travailler ça fait quelques semaines qui
a pas plu du tout chez nous donc les
premières victimes évidemment ce sont
les agriculteurs alors ils sont très
très inquiets les agriculteurs des
réactions qui ne trompe pas c'est que la
fnsea est parti à l'assaut des médias
cette semaine regardé le planning
aujourd'hui de christiane lambert ce
matin sur rmc ce midi sur france bleu ce
soir sur france 5 et son message est
très clair c'est à dire que on s'attend
à des conséquences sur les récoltes de
céréales cet été on écoute mois de mai
un mois charnière il a raison de le dire
le mois de mai c'est le mois où les prix
montent dans la tige de blé s'il y un
déficit d'eau non seulement lépi ne se
forme pas correctement les grains non
plus et ça ampute beaucoup la capacité
de quantité de rendement de ce blé là
s'il ne pleut pas qu'aux météo france
semble le dire oui il y a un vrai risque
d'avoir beaucoup moins de blé cet été
donc on sent que les naisseurs met un
peu la pression sanguine avant via
l'ukraine qui restait donc et ses râles
maintenant la sécheresse aura peut-être
qu il peut pleuvoir puisque c'est encore
possible on ne peut pas écarter ça sauf
que même s'il pleut eh ben on n'est pas
sûr que ça suffise c'est jean pierre
girod qui lui travaille au conseil
économique et social de normandie qui
nous expliquent les sols sont secs donc
même si l'appui revenait le temps que
les sols absorber l'eau se ramollissent
est puis sera se recontacter avec des
ressources souterraines on voit bien que
là on va être en difficulté de toute
manière cet été oui avec le
réchauffement climatique ces épisodes
risque d'être de plus en plus fréquent
de plus en plus nombreux exactement les
sécheresses vont devenir de plus en plus
fréquentes et comme tout ce qui est rare
devient précieux l'eau va devenir
précieux on l'a pas découvert comme ça
fait longtemps qu'on le sait
souvenez-vous
1974 imagine que noël mamère voilà qui
va faire plaisir à noël mamère la
candidature de rené dumont et qu'est ce
qu'il disait rené dumont soit presque 50
ans il vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera et on ne l'a pas entendu à
l'époque elle fait 1,3 pour cent des
voix à l'époque 50 ans plus tard même
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils disent mais
attention faut vraiment de manière
urgente réduire la consommation d'eau
notamment dans l'agriculture n'ont pas
l'impression d'être vraiment entendu
donc quelqu'un qui est hydro logue qui
s'appelle emma 10 à qui un peu le même
métier que vous qui dit ben non on n'est
pas du tout préparé ce qui nous attend
je crois qu'on n'a pas compris ce qu'est
changement climatique on n'a pas compris
ce que l'on est en train dit qu'on est
dans le changement climatique c'est pas
en 2050 ni en 2100 on est déjà en train
de le vivre regarder ce qui se passe en
australie regardez la californie c'est
le modèle qu'on est en train de suivre
sur le plan agricole et donc on vivra
dans cinq ans dans dix ans qu'ils sont
en train de vivre aujourd'hui il arrive
devant le mur alors si on nous dit que
dans cinq ans ou dix ans et comme en
californie forcément qu'est ce qu'on
fait on regarde sur pour savoir comment
ça se passe en californie et donc on
voit que l'an dernier deux fait
effectivement il ya eu un choix à faire
on appelait ça la guerre de l'eau il a
fallu couper l'eau aux agriculteurs
parce que sinon les gens qui habitent en
ville n'avaient plus d'eau potable
d'envoyer l'avenir qui nous attend
ça c'est ça qui nous attend en france le
manque d'eau potable mais ça existe déjà
le réchauffement climatique c'est
maintenant en 2019 il ya déjà des
communes où ils manquaient d'eau potable
donc on a dû amener dans ces communes
l'afutt en corrèze des camions citernes
remplis d'eau potable donc tout ça pour
dire qu'effectivement on s'inquiète pour
les agriculteurs très court terme est la
sécheresse c'est pas un problème
d'agriculteurs c'est un problème qui
concerne tout le monde merci beaucoup
stéphane on va commencer avec vous agnès
du cher on va essayer de comprendre déjà
cet épisode là on comprend déjà qu' on
est loin d'être les seules ces mondiale
ce phénomène on l'a regardé les les
états unis le maghreb une partie de
l'asie l'europe personne n'était pas
renié les sécheresses c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez courant s'est en
particulier dans les périodes d'été où
les saisons sèches de certains un climat
mais par contre ce qui ce qui est assez
globale c'est que dans les endroits qui
ont habituellement souffre de sécheresse
à cause du changement climatique qui
comme la 10ème à aziza est en cours et
est bien c'est sécheresse soit
s'intensifie soit sont plus fréquentes
oui ça c'est vrai la france n'est qu'un
exemple parmi beaucoup d'autres on n'a
pas eu un tel déficit hydrique depuis 25
ans a dit christiane lambert sur les
premiers mois de l'année ça vous validez
comment vous l'expliquez dérèglement
climatique on sait que les nappes
phréatiques aussi alors je suis pas une
spécialiste mais sont déjà peu chargé en
eau de fête du dérèglement et la fait
encore pire donc ce qui caractérise
notre situation maintenant c'est un
déficit de pluie sur de grandes parties
de la france hormis globalement le sud
ouest
depuis durant tout l'hiver en fête c'est
la période où ou en fait les sols des
nappes se rechargent et ce qui permet
les étés qui suivent d hiver donc
d'avoir de l'eau dans les cours d'eau
aussi est donc là il ya eu un déficit de
pluie de plus de 25% dans une plus de la
moitié du territoire français en fait
depuis depuis septembre ce qui fait que
cette recharge n'a pas eu lieu donc les
nappes sont basses les sols sont secs et
les cours d'eau aussi un donc tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge finalement sur
ses ressources en eau en france sauf
donc enfin pas donc pas toutefois les
départements sommes toujours que l'ecc
on parle de sécheresse qu'on parle de
crue c'est pas partout c'est pas partout
en même temps mais donc pour pour deux
tiers du territoire français ben là on
entame l'été enfin là il va saison
croissance des cultures et l'été on
entame dans une mauvaise situation oui
c'est beaucoup quand même un 2/3 gaspard
madness et décrivez nous un petit peu ce
que vous ce que vous vivez 63 % des
agriculteurs concernés par le manque
d'eau à différents degrés bien
évidemment ça va forcément avoir des
conséquences sur les récoltes
sur les récoltes sur sur la qualité du
travail qu'on peut fournir
au delà de la question de l'eau et de au
delà de la question de l'eau il ya aussi
la question de la température c'est à
dire que au delà d'une certaine
température de légumes ne poussent plus
de fait la les extrêmes
pousse-pousse de vers le haut et au
dessus de 35 degrés le blé par exemple
ne pose plus nous pour les légumes c'est
extrêmement problématique aussi
et les conditions de travail sont
extrêmement difficiles ensuite la
sécheresse évidemment le
manque d'eau pénalise largement la
croissance des légumes évidemment oui
alors je vous propose de voir tout de
suite en images - juste rajouté bien sûr
à l'eau c'est quand même on parle
toujours au futur la nôtre
l'intervenant deux précédentes
hydrologue et mme azila le disait mais
c'est déjà la réalité c'est-à-dire le il
ya deux ans on a eu 42 degrés ce qui est
incompatible avec
l'agriculture et ce ne sont pas des
moyens techniques qui vont permettre de
résoudre ces situations vous
personnellement vous n'êtes pas
directement concerné encore sur cet
épisode si besoin alors je vous propose
de voir en images concrètement ce que
vivent deux agriculteurs c'est un
reportage de de clément pernot une
exploitation en picardie et une autre
dans le loiret je vous passe la parole
juste après
ces terres de picardie sont sèches dès
le mois de mai à tel point que les
réserves de foin sont déjà sortis pour
nourrir les vaches selon cyril périvier
éleveurs c'est du jamais vu depuis 25
ans c'est pas normal qu'ils un soleil
ardent à 27 degrés à l'ombre au tout
début du mois de mai c'est pas normal
qu'on soit obligé de fourrage et les
bêtes alors qu'ils viennent de sortir à
l'herbe il ya trois semaines il ya déjà
un manque d'herbe
[Musique]
situation similaire dans le loiret robin
à chaud lui est inquiète pour ses champs
de blé l'agriculteur est déjà contraint
de sortir en urgence le canon à eau pour
sauver sa récolte
temps on n'arrose pas aujourd'hui c'est
50 % de la récolte qui est compromis par
chez nous on est dans des terres
sableuses ce manque d'eau arrive au pire
moment le blé approche de sa phase de
floraison les grains sont encore vides
voilà aujourd'hui on met de l'eau pourra
espérer un bon remplissage et et que ça
les emmène jusqu'à là jusqu'à la moisson
là je peux même pas prendre le ter
aujourd'hui vous voyez c'est c'est du
béton fait sec voilà il ya plus aucune
fraîcheur
l'agriculteur a une capacité d'un rose
âge d'environ deux mois en puisant déjà
dans ses réserves il craint de ne pas
avoir assez d'eau ensuite pour son maïs
cette sécheresse précoce inquiète
d'autant plus les agriculteurs que les
prévisions des prochains mois sont
pessimistes une sécheresse majeure n'est
pas à exclure cet été
alors joël limouzin vous qui nous
regardent et depuis depuis la vendée
quel est votre diagnostic précisément
face à l'ampleur de cette sécheresse on
a compris que les agriculteurs souffrent
qui va souffrir le plus les céréaliers
ce qui cultive le blé l'orge qui
précisément
alors il faut prendre les choses par
étapes effectivement à la période que
nous vivons aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt
les céréales parce que comme ça été dit
dans le reportage on est un stade
fatidique pour le rendement tant en
quantité qu'en qualité
rien n'exclut des possibilités de pluie
au mois de juin fin juin début juillet
au moment où le maïs pour en avoir
besoin
rien ne laisse plus avec des orages qui
peuvent tomber ici et là et c'est ça le
paradoxe que nous vivons depuis quelques
années déjà à savoir une pluviométrie de
plus en plus disparates on a des
périodes longues heures sans pluie
quelquefois des périodes importantes
avec beaucoup de pluie
et c'est là que si on n'a pas compris
que au moment où on a des périodes de
haute soule avec des forte pluviométrie
si on ne stoppe pas c'est tout mais pas
simplement pour dire stocker pour
l'agriculture si on n'a pas une approche
globale
de pouvoir subvenir à l'eau potable
l'equilibre des milieux pour la bio
diverses à mince on vous a perdu citéa
et kanu et moi je suis à proximité du
marais poitevin je vois très bien
comment les choses se passent mais sinon
il faut qu'on ait de l'eau aussi pour
l'agriculture pour die et les périodes
spécifiques et c'est là dessus que le
principe du varennes de l'eau va
justement pour renvoyer dans chacun des
territoires la possibilité de trouver
des solutions pour stocker cette eau moi
ça fait 15 ans 20 ans même que nous
avons mis en place un stockage d'eau sur
l'exploitation nous avons deux réserves
ce qu'on appelle des retenues
collinaires d'un des talweg où nous
avons mis une digue avec de l'argile qui
était dans le fond de du sous sol vous
créez des bassins suffit ciel combien
comprendre de stockage dos et ça
s'entend au sens naturel à la à la base
dans la terre vous faites venir de l'eau
bêtement d'accord c'est de la pluie
c'est l'eau de pluie et ses pluies cette
eau si je ne la collecter pas elle irait
directement la mer donc est ilidio
aujourd'hui en période de fortes pluies
de pouvoir un capter juste ce qu'il faut
pour pouvoir subvenir aux coûts plantes
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui il y à 1,7
pour cent de la pluie qui tombe qui est
stockée pour permettre l'irrigation et
l'agriculture
donc essayons de prendre un peu de recul
en la matière je ne nie pas le
changement climatique les agriculteurs
ont déjà actionné les dispositifs comme
la niveau de mon collègue maraîchers sur
votre plateau où on est plus inquiet sur
les problématiques d'amplitude thermique
et que ce soit pour des maraîchers tour
de la prairie au delà de 25 degrés la
prairie ne pousse plus haut tas de 40
degrés effectivement le maïs s'il n'est
pas y arriver il va complètement
desséchées s'il ya une grosse canicule
au moment de la fécondation du maïs que
vous apportiez de l'eau ou pas il peut y
avoir une brûlure au moment de la
fécondation et brûlures de feuilles de
vigne donc déjà sur la sécheresse vous
avez une forme de solution c'est
réfléchir à des stockages dos au moment
des pluies bon ben voilà le débat est
lancé noël mamère je voyais de ce côté
là pas mal hausser le sourcil ça peut
pas aider un petit peu logique j'ai déjà
vu eux je suis limousin dans d'autres
émissions défendre exactement les mêmes
théories je ne nie pas le fait que
l'irrigation est une nécessité pour
l'agriculture mais sa dépense tout et
tout dépend de sa comme définition que
l'on donne agriculture est ce qu'il
s'agit de subvenir aux besoins d'une
agriculture industrielle telle que celle
que décrit eux monsieur limousin
notamment l'exploitation du maïs qui est
un maïs hybride qui eux demandent
beaucoup beaucoup d'eau durant l'été
parce qu'il faut des hauts rendements et
qui s'est inscrit dans une logique
contre laquelle nous battons les
écologistes comme la confédération
paysanne d'ailleurs dont
on veut être les concurrents du brésil
de l'ukraine ont fait des du du maïs
pour l'ensilage ou pour l'exportation or
nous avons nous le savons tous des
besoins en alimentation qui sont très
importants et donc plutôt que d'
artificialisés des sols comme ils le
font parce que monsieur limousin n'a pas
parlé de et aussi les retenues
collinaires spa des retenues collinaires
y en as oui bien sûr
les passings cesson c'est ce sont des
nappes de plastique que l'on pose sur du
terrain qui pourrait être agricole donc
il ne devient plus qui devient
artificialisés et qui sont l'équivalent
d'à peu près 10 et terrains de football
dans la région de monsieur limousin en
vendée il y a à peu près un peu plus de
près de 200 hectares de ces de ses
bassines et maintenant on projette des
méga bassiner quand il nous dit qu'on
récupère l'eau de pluie oui mais il ne
dit pas qu'on récupère l'eau si les
rivières et de la nappe souterraine
c'est à dire de la même pratique et il
ne nous dit pas un problème
il ne nous dit pas que ça dessine elles
sont victimes de l'évaporation pendant
l'été si entre eux estimés par les
scientifiques les hydrogéologues entre
20 et 60% et moi ce que je regrette
c'est que ses bassines sont financées à
70 % par des fonds publics alors qu'elle
vienne en conflits d'usagé avec d'autres
agriculteurs qui ne pratiquent pas la
même agriculture qui font par exemple de
l'agro écologie et aussi avec des
besoins domestiques et j'ajouterais pour
terminer parce que ce que disait rené
dumont est très juste si on prend le
plan global il ya 2,5 milliards d'hommes
de femmes et d'enfants qui aujourd'hui
sont victimes de sécheresse et donc
qu'ils sont victimes d'un manque d'eau
si on on descend dans l'entonnoir et
qu'on regarde chez nous mais on
s'aperçoit que tout le tout ce que nous
prenons comme terres agricoles pour de
l'agro industrie c'est ça de moins pour
raccourcir le parcours du producteur au
consommateur et donc la priorité c'est
pas l'exportation laborit et si
l'alimentation du pays pour l'instant
souveraineté alimentaire en france qui
est qui est plutôt garanties même si
effectivement il ya un problème de
production on le voit bien face
qu'il faut doubler la production pour
faire re pour pour résoudre le problème
que pose l'ukraine parce que ça c'est le
contraire de ce qui est du green deal
c'est le coin mais là y'a quand même
obligation de connexion au
maghreb notamment dont soir dominique
chargé merci de nous avoir rejoints vous
présidez la coopération agricole
agricole et vous êtes vous même
agriculteur en loire atlantique on est
déjà sur une forme de débat de monde
d'après si j'ose dire en tout cas de
solutions très concrètes face à
l'urgence alors on va revenir sur la
question de l'eau mais face à l'urgence
le gouvernement a débloqué déjà une
enveloppe de l'argent 20 millions
d'euros et puis a permis d'aller pour le
fourrage chercher les terrains alors
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait beaucoup de
terrain en france militaire la sncf les
agriculteurs vont pouvoir aller ancien
aéroport exactement vont pouvoir fauché
pour nourrir
et bien leur bête c'est déjà ça il ya
une réactivité là dessus au moins oui
c'est bien oui on a eu une réactivité du
gouvernement par rapport à la situation
d'urgence devant laquelle on est mais
pour revenir un petit peu sur le débat
qui était celui qui précédait la
question de l'eau reste une question de
toute façon centrale extrêmement comment
dire
et puis épidermique on va dire mais
c'est une question centrale il faudra de
l'eau si je regarde la façon dont se
passe aujourd'hui cette évolution
changement climatique moi ça fait trente
ans que je suis agriculteur
effectivement en trente ans je perçois
ce que sont sur mon exploitation les
conséquences du changement climatique
concrètes l'an dernier il ya un dicton
en agriculture qui dit le mois de mai
perd tout le mois de mai rattrape tout
l'an dernier le mois de mai à tout
rattraper nous avons eu des puits nous
n'avions pas au mois d'avril cette année
on nous avons eu quelques pluies sans
doute pas assez au mois d'avril pour
l'instant ils n'ont pas de plus en mai
en revanche l'an dernier après la
sécheresse que nous avions eue sur le
mot que nous avions nous avons eu des
pluies abondantes au moment de la
récolte des céréales ce qui est aussi
anormal donc la question en fait de
l'eau c'est aussi celle de la
répartition il ya la densité mis aussi
la répartie sur on a une répartition des
pluviométries et qui devient
complètement aléatoire et moi je pense
que c'est ce qui justifie qu'on s'engage
aujourd'hui dans une gestion différente
de l'eau que celles qu'on utilise alors
savait pas forcément dire monsieur
mamère nationaux mosan mais ça veut pas
mais je rejoins monsieur limousine je
suis devant la même problématique elle
ça veut pas dire ça ne ça ne veut pas
dire pour autant comme je l'entendais
que ça milite systématiquement pour une
ce que vous appelez une agriculture
industrielle dont je ne connais même pas
la définition ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que dans les solutions qu'on doit
mettre en oeuvre l'eau est forcément un
facteur indispensable mais c'est pas le
seul on doit aussi travailler c'est ce
sur quoi nous sommes engagés au niveau
de la coopération agricole dans
l'accompagnement du changement des
pratiques et du changement
des cultures de deux des rotations et
des assolements sur les expéditions je
vais vous citer un exemple sur mon
exploitation il ya une dizaine quinzaine
d'années on est effectivement sur un
affouragement qui était très largement
influencé ou conditionnés par nos
récoltes d'automne c'est à dire celles
effectivement qui ont besoin d'eau l'été
on avait sans doute mon problème d'eau
qu'on en est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui devant les problèmes qu'on a
on a inversé ou en tout cas modifier nos
pratiques et on a appuyé notre
affouragement sur des récoltes qui sont
davantage des récoltes de printemps et
donc on a diminué notre risque par
rapport aux pluies d'été c'est aussi ça
les solutions il va falloir aussi que
l'on cherche à la fois des espèces mais
aussi des variétés qui présentent moins
de risque et monza ce gars est d'aller
chez vous je pense qu'on a des solutions
à chercher saison donc moi la polémique
sur la façon dont on doit utiliser l'eau
j'entends ce qu'on dit elle et les
coquins et oui on sera tous concurrents
on est tous concurrents donc il faut
qu'on travaille ses terres peu sûr c'est
que monsieur mamère verts c'est un peu
le sens de ce qui a été fait aujourd'hui
au niveau du var hendou c'est d'essayer
de trouver une une utilisation de loups
qui tiennent compte de l'ensemble des
usagers des usagers
la gestion du dispositif ce barème de
look de quoi parle-t-on précisément pour
qu on plus le varennes de l'eau c'est
une c'est une heure et est c'est un
dialogue c'est une somme de réunion qui
était mise en place par le ministre de
l'agriculture justement devant les
problématiques récurrentes que l'on
rencontrait pas seulement d'ailleurs sur
les questions de l'eau mais sur les
questions du juge elle aussi bien parce
qu'on a des gels tardifs aujourd'hui
donc sur les questions liées aux
conséquences du changement climatique
est l'objectif de ce varennes de l'eau
c'était d'avoir une un échange entre les
différents usagers entre les différentes
sensibilités on va dire politiques et de
la société sur la résilience
amélioration de la résilience est
d'ailleurs pas le bahreïn de l'eau c'est
le vans de l'eau et des conséquences du
changement climatique
on les fait rentrer c'est le chant que
les quêtes ouvelle chantier sur la
résidence de l'exploitation sur les
conséquences de la sécheresse est
effectivement sur l'utilisation aménagé
au maximum cette ressource de plus en
plus rare quelles sont les solutions
qu'elles sont au fond des pistes d'une
agriculture de demain face à une ou de
plus en plus rare est ce qu'il faut
aller vers de l'innovation au goutte à
goutte pour trouver des systèmes
innovants d'irrigation est ce qu'il faut
changer les cultures et ne plus faire de
maïs par exemple très consommateur donne
est-ce qu'il faut qu'elles sont l'église
je tiens quand même à préciser qu'il
s'agit du vin rennes agricole de l'eau
donc c'est quand même piloté par le
ministère de l'agriculture
juste point d'information après ce que
j'aimerais dire également par rapport à
ce que je viens d'entendre c'est que
quand on a de l'appuyer en était en
période de déficit enfin caen et qu'on
manque d'eau je pense qu'on devrait s'en
réjouir en fait donc il ya plusieurs
manières de la capitale et enfin pas de
la capter mais de l'utiliser faire des
retenues n'en n'est qu'une parmi
d'autres et c'est à mon avis pas
forcément la meilleure il ya une autre
solution très très utiles et
sous-employés à mon avis qui est de
favoriser l'infiltration dans les sols
donc ça implique au mans ça implique de
changer certains certaines pratiques
agricoles pour pour qu'ils aient plus de
et moins d'intensité liste des pays
refusant de s'excuser de la matière
organique dans les sols qui permettent
donc à la fois une meilleure
infiltration et un meilleur maintien de
l'eau dans les sols et puis donc ensuite
dans les solutions on a le paillage
aussi parler qu'est ce que c'est le
paillage c'est pour éviter des périodes
de somme nulle où les sols évapore
beaucoup éviter l'évaporation des sols
plus donc de
deux mètres de la paille sur des coupes
gaspard madness bah oui j'ai quelques
réactions à tous à les y aller jusqu'à
maintenant
monsieur limousin parler du caractère
global effectivement le changement
climatique c'est quelque chose de global
et c'est extrêmement complexe
compte une planification mêmes c'est à
dire c'était la production là on a bien
l'impression que mon propre son sens le
on peut passer c'est très difficile de
réduire le des mécanismes complexes de
la vie de la régulation météo de la
régulation de l'eau et tout ça donc sont
pas des solutions nice mme c'est pas des
solutions techniques qui vont toujours
être très limité très focalisés et qui
en fait engendre de plus en plus de
problèmes au fur et à mesure noël mamère
disait que une bassine ses 15 hectares
de plastique effectivement d'où vient
cette eau c'est absolument faux que ça
vient d'eux de l'année ce n'est pas du
tout du ruissellement et la
confédération paysanne l'a prouvé en
démontant la pompe
justement pour montrer que ça ne venait
pas de la pluie d'une bassine à cram
chaban
dans les dents en charente maritime donc
il était c'était un acte symbolique pour
bien montrer que c'était pompée dans la
nappe or ces taux étaient piégés sous
terre ce qui est le mécanisme normale du
cycle de l'eau elle était bien à l'abri
au frais pure on la met dans du
plastique donc déjà avec une petite
contamination chimique et à l'air libre
et elle s'évapore et après on va vivre
un rosé du maïs c'est un petit problème
le caractère industriel donc vous le
effectivement il est très difficile à
définir précisément mais c'est une
réalité c'est à dire que mon en moins
d'un siècle d'agriculture industrielle
on a réussi à dégrader tous les soirs
lou grosso modo et engendrer un tiers de
la responsabilité du changement
climatique à l'échelle planétaire
pourtant l'agriculture datent du
néolithique sur dix mille ans
l'equilibre agro-sylvo-pastorale
l'agriculture familiale en
polyculture-élevage
agro-sylvo-pastorale c'est à dire les
plantes l'élevage et la facette très
divers l'agriculture industrielle mais
s'est imposé avec deux pieds le
machinisme d'un côté et la chimie de
l'autre le machinisme et fortement
émetteurs par son extractives isme pour
construire les machines personnes
l'utilisation du pétrole ça et rod
énormément les sols donc l'eau nous re
l'eau ruisselle et ne s'infiltre plus
dans les nappes tandis que la chimie
elle est notamment à la hongrie a ajouté
c'est très clair j'ai eu terminé stable
et parce que les moulins qui nous attend
il aimerait bien vous répondre aussi
mais il faut bien je crois que je vais
pas parler jusqu'à maintenant
amener le un engrais de kilos 1 1 kg
d'engrais azotés est égale 1 1 kg de
pétrole et lorsqu'on va m c'est cet
azote sur le sol c'est extrêmement
émetteurs de protoxyde d azote qui est
un gaz qui est 40 fois supérieur à
l'effet du seul qui a un effet 40 fois
supérieur à celui du co2 c'est à dire
que cette agriculture industrielle qui
est basée sur l'utilisation du pétrole
génère elle-même la sécheresse le
réchauffement climatique donc ce serait
bien si elle est tempérée la remontée
d'être des températures donc ce médecin
du soliste nisme technique industriel
qui va nous sortir gagnant aurez-vous
fait le premier épisode voilà à quoi ce
jeu les références ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire des petites exploitations ça
veut dire qu'on revient à ça un modèle
de pression c'est venise c'est pas la
question de deux vous n'allez pas nous
faire le procès encore de la défense de
la bougie contre le progrès je vous pose
des questions je regarde par exemple les
questions qu'a été la question qui a été
posée au baccalauréat aujourd'hui en
sciences économiques et sociales qui
pour vous montrer qu'elle est le
conditionnement dans lequel on met les
enfants après il faut pas s'étonner que
les étudiants d'agroparistech ses huit
étudiantes d'agroparistech est dit on on
veut bien tenu et à pratiquer une
agriculture qui nous mène dans le mur
la question
à des élèves du bac nous on nous la
question était la suivante pense
qu'elles sont les innovations que l'on
peut mettre en oeuvre pour reculer les
limites écologiques de la croissance
donc c'est faire croire et gérard gamble
de gaspard malo vient de l'expliquer
très brillant très très intelligemment
s'était essayé de faire comprendre que
l'innovation pourrait nous sauver d'un
modèle qui est en train de montrer ses
limites et comme on a essayé de le dire
ici il n'est pas question de monter les
écologistes contre les agriculteurs de
montrer la confédération paysanne contre
la fnsea cette question de l'eau elle
est majeure parce qu'elle est
transversale les lots c'est un bien
commun il faut qu'on prenne ça en
conscience et ce qu'elle nous avait
expliqué rené dumont dès 1974 si c'est
un bien commun il faut que tout le monde
discute ensemble à savoir
compris comment ces mois sont très
concrètes imaginez un modèle très facile
ça soit ça ressemble agriculteurs de
demain très concret l'agriculture de
demain c'est une agriculture qui créent
des emplois c'est à dire qu'ils ne tuent
pas les paysans qui ne détruit pas
l'environnement et qui ne propose pas et
qui ne provoque pas des problèmes de
santé publique parce que vous l'avez
quand même vu les pesticides ça provoque
quand même pas mal de dégâts dans la
santé et qui nourrit la france aux
séries qui nous
bouffent la malbouffe créé les deux
maladie de la pauvreté que sont le
diabète et l'obésité d'un élément sortir
tout le sillage plus vertueuses et la
plus écologique possible je vais donner
quand même la parole à la défense il se
jouait dreams d'un truand arrêter de
détruire voilà la planète avec elle pas
que monsieur
de l'eau joël limouzin convaincus ou pas
par par cette esquisse de deux solutions
pour demain non je pense qu'il faut
qu'on arrête avec les clichés on a
besoin de toutes les agricultures il que
ce soit une agriculture de production
que ce soit une agriculture en
agriculture biologique que ce soit de la
belle rouge et aidant on doit pouvoir
répondre à toutes les capacités des
consommateurs je tiens simplement à
rappeler que de remettre des vérités oui
les réserves de substitution permettent
de récupérer l'eau des nappes et vous
avez raison c'est bien l'eau des nappes
phréatiques qui sont pris monsieur
mamère qui sont prises lorsqu'on en
période de hautes zone est depuis 15 ans
monsieur mamère monsieur depuis 15 ans
nous avons une expérience sur le
département ou france nature
environnement siège à tous les comités
sécheresse de mon département et nous
avons fait la démonstration malgré tout
les sécheresses chaque année que nous
avons augmenté le niveau d'eau dans le
marais poitevin vous le dites moi
monsieur le président vous 5 deux sèvres
environnement s'est séparé de votre
coopérative qui a lancé les bassines
attendez on va pas faire un débat
extrêmement locales ces personnes
arrivent
changer le débat va malheureusement
s'achevait donc on va les faire très
vite annuel du charme à tous la parole
une fois pour conclure tout d'abord
quand on prend de l'eau dans les nappes
pour les mettre dans ces fameuses
bassine
l'objectif en fait un des objectifs il
me semble c'est de contourner une forme
de la loi puisque quand on est en
période de sécheresse d'arrêter
sécheresse personnes la plupart des
usages sauf l'eau potable et les la
sécurité civile n'a le droit de prendre
de l'eau ni dans les cours d'eau ni dans
les nappes quand l'eau est dans une
bassine elle est la propriété des
personnes qui ont construit cette
bassine et à ce moment là ils ne sont
plus soumis aux arrêtés sécheresse donc
c'est une manière de contourner de
privatiser en fait le bien commun ça
c'est la première chose et je pense
qu'il ya d'autres manières de maintenir
une agriculture est leur casque ça la
deuxième chose la coach traitement roule
exercent et que certes l'agriculture est
un utilisateur important de l'eau et je
soutiens tout à fait qu'ils puissent le
faire mais ça ne parle pas du tout les
seuls en termes de consommation d'eau en
france l'agriculture ses 45% l'eau
potable c'est 20% et puis le
refroidissement
et on l'a bien vu quoi penser qu'à
l'avenir on aura de nouvelles
restrictions occupé sur sur l'eau
potable ça a eu lieu en 2019 il ya des
départements qui sont déjà aujourd'hui
j'ai ce qu'il vous attend bien sûr au
fond d'abord des restrictions
pense que les restrictions pense que les
restrictions sont des mesures de
prévention par rapport aux niveaux des
nappes à un moment donné et c'est plutôt
des bonnes mesures moi ce que je
voudrais dire à mam d'abord je ne me
désole pas de voir l'eau tombe il était
serré c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
voulu dire j'ai dit simplement condé on
était aujourd'hui dans une gestion des
extrêmes en terme de pluviométrie comme
d'autres accidents climatiques qu'il
fallait qu'on apprenne à gérer autrement
moi je pense que profiter d'un débat ou
d'une vingtaine comme ça proposé
l'agriculture vous a oublié le tassement
du sol mais le tassement du sol
effectivement je ne nie pas aller que
l'agriculture s'est développée sur la
mécanisation et l'utilisation d'intrants
chimiques mais vous avez parfaitement
raison aujourd'hui le web et mime mais
on le sait tous mais le modèle est le
modèle changé avec
les années de sauteurs les agriculteurs
le demande le changement comme le
changement pratique elle nous les
accompagnons ils le demandent pourquoi
le plan fit aussitôt phyto sanitaires et
phytosanitaires n'a pas été respecté et
augmenter l'utilisation des pièces non
ça aussi c'est le cas ça aussi que
monsieur mamère c'est
cette émission je propose un cocheur
débat en font les séduit style s'achève
on a essayé d'esquisser les enjeux merci
infiniment
on va s'arrêter là je vous promets que
vous aurez vous aurez autour de paroles
donc je laisse à chacun
chacun parle et pourtant
c'est très bien de dire que toutes les
agricultures leur place sauf qu'il en a
une qui prend toute la place et ben
voilà vous et puis vous avez pu
l'exprimer en tout cas vous voyez vous
n'êtes pas bâillonner merci beaucoup
merci d'être sûr d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci monsieur limousin on va
changer à présent totalement de sujets
et s'arrêtait sur ce que l'on appelle
les wagner cette milice russe ultra
secrète suspecté d'être très présente et
du pire en ukraine c'est d'ailleurs là
où elle est née en ukraine en 2014
aujourd'hui ces mercenaires
représenterait 5000 hommes déployés sur
tous les terrains chauds de la planète
là où poutine estime qu'il a des
intérêts de réalisatrice leur ont
consacré un film exceptionnel on a plein
de questions à leur poser à cet exil ni
à bolt shakhova et alexandra joue c'est
d'abord ce sujet de kathia gilder elle
nous rejoint juste après
si on vous invite alexandra jousset
xenia 1 doel shakhova c'est pour vous
parler d'un documentaire exceptionnel le
vôtre
pendant des mois vous avez enquêté sur
wagner cette société militaire privée
qui emploie officiellement de simples
soldats chargés de gérer la sécurité
dans les pays où les intérêts de la
russie sont menacés en fait vous nous
dites que ce sont des mercenaires sans
scrupules accusé d'avoir commis des
exactions en centrafrique libye syrie et
surtout d'être l'armé secrète de
vladimir poutine a tenu que soudas
vous avez approché au plus près ces
hommes de l'ombre vous avez rencontré
l'un d'eux marach gaby du lean 56 ans
mercenaires repenti il est le premier
wagner qui témoignent à visage découvert
je voyais très bien que c'était pas
l'armée
je me rendais bien compte que tout ça
n'était pas très légal c'était évident
alexandra jousset xenia bolshakova vous
êtes des journalistes reporters
indépendante et chevronnés habitué des
zones de guerre vous avez travaillé
ensemble pour faire ce film au péril de
votre vie il ya eu sept cette pression
psychologique énorme nous on arrivait en
centrafrique que notre chambre était
survolée par un drone avec des
mercenaires blond armés qui étaient en
train d'actionner ce drone pour votre
film vous êtes allés en russie à l'est
de l'oural après un an d'enquêté vous
avez pu retrouver vassili un homme lié à
l'organisation
il a accepté de vous parler
comment vivre avec ça soutient faut bien
le faire oui le meurtre est un péché ce
n'est pas toi qui a donné la vie ce
n'est pas à toi de la reprendre mais ça
fait partie de ce travail soit tu sois
tu te fais tuer ses mercenaires vous les
avez vu de vos yeux dans les rues de
bangui en centrafrique le visage masqué
le pays riches en or et en diamant est
l'une des zones d'action de wagner
pillage tortures viols là où le groupe
passe il est accusé de semer la mort en
toute impunité il a entraîné non j'étais
au sol et m'ont violée à tour de rôle
les wagner sont aussi présents dans le
dombass pour soutenir les séparatistes
pro-russes alors aujourd'hui alexandra
jousset xenia bolshakova on vous pose la
question combien sont-ils en ukraine et
faut-il voir derrière les massacres de
butch à irbine balade yann car la main
de wagner
bonsoir à toutes les deux c'est le
diable shakhova alexandra jousset merci
d'être avec nous ce soir on va revenir
évidemment sur ces milices russe la
manière dont elles se sont développées
c'est une milice extrêmement secrète
extrêmement difficile d'enquêter on a
compris vous avez pris des risques que
vous avez été menacé sur sûr c'est sur
ces wagner mais partons avec le sujet de
katia de ceux de ce conflit
d'aujourd'hui en ukraine qu est ce qu on
sait précisément de leur implication sur
le terrain ukrainien aujourd'hui
en comparaison à la solde à de l'armée
régulière les hommes de wagner sont
quand même en minorité
ils sont pas très nombreux mais je
dirais il ya plusieurs bataillons
d'après nos sources il serait entre 300
et 500 sur tout le territoire
1750 et me disait trois bataillons non
non c'est bon bref en tout cas ils sont
cassés c'est une goutte d'eau par
rapport à tout ce bon teint jambes de
soldats sur place
leur mission est lady est ce qu'ils font
voilà est-ce qu'on a des précisions sur
des informations sur la nature exacte de
leurs missions aux débuts de taille vous
avez dit qu'ils étaient là pour
assassiner volodymyr zelensky après on a
eu des informations sur des opérations
de sabotage sur les infrastructures est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'ils font sur place
bah en fait ils sont surtout envoyé en
éclaireur sur des positions c'est à dire
qu'effectivement la mission de sabotage
pourrait paraître assez enfin bas avec
le profil de ce qu'ils savent faire donc
on les envoie sur des positions il n'ya
pas encore l'armée l'armée russe il sert
un peu de chair à canon quand même il
faut pas le faut pas le nier qu'ils vont
sur des positions qui sont difficiles
difficile à prendre ils vont derrière
les lignes nous on n'a pas eu les
informations selon lequelles ils avaient
ils avaient écumé les rues de kiev pour
éliminer volodymyr zelensky pour nous il
était plus en dons basse ils ont réussi
était dans la région du nord est
évidemment de kiev
mais c'était vraiment plus pour des
missions de sabotage est-ce qui est ce
qu'ils ont parce qu'on sait qu'ils sont
extrêmement violent parfois coupables de
barbarie un il ya eu il ya des
accusations de l'onu notamment
centrafrique est ce qu'on sait s'ils ont
participé à des crimes de guerre
français alors évidemment l'ont donc on
sait pas non plus qui parmi les
solutions
on a quelques informations comme disait
alexandra
de source non notamment une des
personnes qui témoignent dans le film
qui lui même est en train de combattre
en ukraine mais plutôt vers la partie
est du pays qui nous a confirmé
effectivement que dans la région de kiev
pas dans le pas dans la capitale pendant
les rues de kiev dans la région de
quérir pine beach à il y avait des
mercenaires qui étaient présents mais
l'essentiel
des opérations militaires et menée par
l'armée régulière dans cette région là
alors est-ce qu'il ya eu des crimes de
guerre commis par les hommes de wagner
c'est possible c'est probable pour
l'instant on en a absolument aucune
preuve et ce sera un petit peu prématuré
d'avancer ce pourquoi poutine en a fait
un groupe privé totalement à part qu'est
ce que c'est le déni de plausibilité et
pourquoi ça la rend jetant le diplo
habilité donc c'est déjà c'est on
rappelle toujours parce que c'est un
concept qui américains ont qui a été
inventé par la cia donc c'est ça
n'appartient pas abouti l'idée c'est
vraiment il ya deux axes dans ce déni le
premier c'est de pouvoir envoyer ses
troupes sur des terrains où il a pas
officiellement envie d'être donc c'était
le cas en libye en centrafrique en syrie
il était dans les airs mais pas sur le
terrain proprement parler et la deuxième
c'est aussi vis-à-vis de sa population
civile
comme
depuis les guerres de tchétchénie
d'afghanistan la mort de soldats russes
et est très peu acceptent enfin mal
acceptée mal prise par la population
civile du coup c'était une façon d'être
engagés dans des opérations tout en
cachant le coût humain de ces opérations
donc est vraiment un but international
et j'allais dire vis-à-vis de la russie
est plus du peuple russe et puis je ne
peux juste pour ajouter aussi un élément
est super important c'est aussi une
façon de pouvoir se dédouaner en cas de
crimes de guerre c'est à dire en cas de
crimes commis sur le terrain c'est on va
dire des mercenaires de saguenay ont
violé temps en temps de femmes et bien
le kremlin veut c'est pas moi ça
n'existe pas wagner née wagner étant une
société totalement fantôme il n'y a pas
de responsabilité donc le déni de
faisabilité c'est aussi cet outil qui
est utilisé
pour se dédouaner de crimes potentiels
commis sur le terrain alors depuis votre
film un homme parle pour la première
fois un ancien wagner à visage découvert
dont le film et puis dans un livre qui
est publié récemment chez michel lafon
il s'appelle marrade gaby du lean
d'ailleurs livres dont voilà vous avez
participé
la direction de cet ouvrage traduction
avec des cas dorman de libération pour
lui il n'ya pas de doute c'est poutine
qui est derrière wagner pour vous il
n'ya pas de doute non plus quels sont
les éléments qui peuvent montrer que
cette milice et à la solde du crem mara
tu ne dis jamais que
poutine est derrière a les nerfs il dit
les lasers de la défense a fait il y
fait très attention aux mots qu'ils
utilisent c'est à dire qu'il sait très
bien qui peut pas dire tout et n'importe
quoi il et il aimerait bien dire que
cucine derrière wagner mais il peut pas
se le permettre parce qu'il a un petit
peu peur d'avoir dérobé il va déjà
falloir battre avait pas rien de rien
quand il l'a dit en interview mêmes nous
on n'y croyez pas on ne s'attendait pas
à ce qu'il le disait de manière aussi
aussi brut parce que c'est vraiment la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
à dire que l'on sait que wagner existe
mais si vous voulez réussir à relier sa
au kremlin de manière officielle c'est
ce qu'on appelle un gros risque le
smoking gun c'est quand même toute une
série d' indices
l'avion de chasse en syrie en libye en
libye pardonnez moi il ya des choses qui
permettent ils sont formés pas loin de
base du ministère de la défense qu'elle
sous lesquels sont les faisceaux
d'indicés qui montrent ce lien il ya des
preuves vous avez mentionné la fameuse
base qui de wagner qui s'est tué à
quelques encablures d'une base du à gm
lui qui est le renseignement militaire
russes les hommes sont formés là bas il
ya des documents qui existe qui prouve
que des commandants de wagner passent
commande directement au ministère de la
défense pour avoir des armements donc ça
c'est des documents surtout qu'ils ont
été retrouvés en libye il ya des
témoignages il ya un autre élément
notamment que nous on a essayé documenté
qu'on a dont on parle dans le film c'est
les armes qui sont fournis aux
mercenaires en centrafrique donc c'est
des armes aux russes qui vient du
ministère de la défense et tout ça c'est
plus que des faisceaux d'indicés des
cadeaux si jamais vous montrer parce que
j'ai pas le temps de montrer un extrait
mais c'est intéressant de vous avoir je
préfère vous entende du film et cette
photo dimitri ou de keane le fondateur
de wagner c'était son nom de guerre
wagner a gardé a gardé le nom pour pour
la milice avec poutine qui est dmitri
hooch chine il ya une photo va la voir
elle est dans le film il lui remet une
décoration il est photographié avec
poutine c'est ça c'est aussi le signe
qu'il ya cette collusion oui non mais
2,12 lumière là que le coach jaune est
évidente aussi dans dans tous les
faisceaux d'indicés à l'utilisation des
moyens logistiques de l'armée donc si
vous dire que tous les soldats de wagner
qui sont arrivées par an pl au mali ils
le font dans des îles ou chine qui
appartiennent à l'armée russe donc vous
dites évidemment il ya une collusion
mais si vous voulez poutine continue à
dire c'est pas nous et en fait tu en as
marsa un décret signé d'avant delà des
murs poutine et là par exemple cette
remise de décorations les photos qu'on a
vus c'était pour des faits de guerre qui
en syrie s'est jamais évidemment voilà
c'était jamais où c'était y combattent
elle détaille ce qu elle fait partie
quand même aussi de tout le narratif
russe de nous on était le rempart contre
l'islamisme radical wagner même mara tu
aimes aussi à rappeler que c'est eux qui
sont allés combattre palmyre qui ont
repris pas de mire l'état islamique donc
qu'ils étaient du même côté à un moment
que les occidentaux donc ça voilà
maintenant relier en disant que c'est
vladimir poutine et prend son téléphone
écrit et qui dit vous allez là c'est
compliqué c'est en tout cas personne à
charge et d'ailleurs depuis cette photo
où ils ont été aperçus ensemble plus
jamais à dmitry autres qu'ils n'étaient
pas plafonnés à la plus tôt non
seulement il ya plus de photos mais il
ya plus d'apparitions publiques il n'y a
plus rien à dire que c'est aussi un
signe
du fait que cette fuite a été
probablement perçu comme quelque chose
d' extrêmement gênant au kremlin et se
sont dit plus jamais ça en quelques mots
qui sont les wagner quelles sont leurs
profils
cet ancien commando cet ancien milicien
qui dit que les profits sont très divers
parmi les wagner c'est quoi ces des
trentenaires on gagne bien sa vie quand
on s'engage dans cette milice on estime
l'ansés logés on gagne bien sa vie par
rapport aux standards russe c'est à dire
que tous les gens qui ont vu le film on
dit mais je comprends même pas comment
ils peuvent risquer leur peau pour 1800
ou 3000 euros oui mais il faut pas il
faut enfin il faut rappeler quand même
que le salaire moyen c'est 500 euros
donc je veux dire c'est des gens pour
eux c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent
ensuite c'est souvent des réservistes
donc c'est quand même des gens qui ont
un lien avec l'armée si ça sort pas de
nulle part sur les tranches d'âge et sur
les âges c'est compliqué à dire parce
que en fait le fils le profil évolue
aussi en fonction de plus amples et
spécialistes on sait que les
spécialistes peuvent être recrutés
jusqu'à beaucoup plus tard donc comme
ils ont besoin de gens qui savent
combattre des gens de réformes et de
l'armée mais qui aurait 45 50 ans il les
embauches par exemple et en ce moment
aussi ils font ça c'est quelque chose de
nouveau dont on parle pas dans le film
et il fonce et des formations pour des
équipements un petit peu plus moderne
mais il faut que la personne embauchée
et déjà une base et c'est ce que disait
alexandre à tous on soit à minima fait
un service militaire soit on était
militaire professionnel il n'y a pas de
novice chez wagner il ya aussi une autre
catégorie de personnes c'était des des
ruches volontaire des combattants
volontaires qui avait participé à la
campagne de la du début de la guerre
dans le donbass en 2014 et 2015 des
jeunes gars qui étaient partis la fleur
au fusil avec un patriotisme débordant
en disant on va soutenir les russes les
russophones opprimés dans cette région
donc à l'est de l'ukraine et ségala dont
marc atos y parle dans son livre cd cdc
des jeunes qui avaient pas forcément eu
d'expérience militaire mais qui ont
passé deux trois ans à faire la guerre
et qui eux ont été le principal terreau
de recrutement de la compagnie militaire
privée merci merci à toutes les deux sur
quoi vous allez travailler à présent
vous continuer à enquêter vous sur la
russie les de le dire on continue sur la
rue si on continue à enquêter sur wagner
cdc des sujets qui ne lâche pas c'est
des sujets qui sont extrêmement riches
il vous la chose est toujours menacée ou
va mieux il se rappellera de bons
souvenirs qu'on fera quelque chose qui
sortira je pense mais pour l'instant on
n'est pas particulièrement menacée non
en tout cas merci beaucoup voyez ce film
il est toujours en replay sur sur le
site de france 5 il est exceptionnel
merci beaucoup pour cet pour cette
enquête merci vraiment c'est l'heure de
retrouver nos a franchi à présent pour
leur parti pris ce soir évidemment d'un
gamin pour les 577 carnet de campagne
quotidien sur des législatives le regard
de joseph macé scaron sur des derniers
jours de jean castex à matignon dont
vous pouvez repartir à daisy merci et
puis et puis comme chaque semaine la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand très
inspiré ce soir par le film de cédric
klapisch encore nos a franchi les voici
merci d'être d'être avec nous on
commence avec qui on commence avec vous
j'ai pas votre chronique il fonde la
donne et ja personne ne me l'a donnée l
eelam elle toute neige a alors les
législatives comme d'habitude carnet de
campagne vous nous parler ce soir d'un
certain eric zemmour oui myriam ça y est
j'ai pas l'os et définitive c'est var
matin et france inter ton sorti l'info
ce matin eric zemmour le principal
intéressé l'a confirmé dans la journée
sur son compte twitter il mènera ce beau
et grand combat il a choisi la 4e
circonscription du var et il a donné
rendez vous sur une plage de cogolin ça
ne s'invente pas la plage elle s'appelle
les marines oui oui alors eric zemmour
dit vouloir mener le combat sauf qu'en
réalité on sait qu'il ya une petite
musique 1 où tout le monde s'étonner que
les cadres de reconquête n'aille pas au
combat c'était d'ailleurs un des angles
d'attaqué du rassemblement national ben
voila je jette à l'eau il a recueilli
près de 17% des voix dans cette cire
costa être compliqué mais on va on va
suivre évidemment cette cette
circonscription et la campagne elle va
vous vouliez nous parlait encore de
ensemble vous êtes plonger à nouveau
dans les investitures de la majorité
présidentielle est cette fois vous nous
parler de celles qui ne sont pas encore
dans la liste alors effectivement myriam
on m'a annoncé juste avant de rentrer
emplettes aucune liste pourrait sortir
d'ici quelques minutes j'espère qu'on ne
dira rien de fou on va mettre un peu de
conditionnel parce que ce qui est vrai
hier n'est pas forcément aujourd'hui
alors effectivement aussi mis à
plusieurs dans la rédac en mode fichier
excel carte de france pour voir qui
n'était pas encore investi en outre-mer
tout n'est pas encore décidée il ya 14
conscription où il n'y a pas de candidat
en marche enfin de la majorité
présidentielle celle de barbara pompili
officiellement ne s'est pas si la
ministre a déjà décidé et puis il ya
certaines circonscriptions qui pourrait
rester vides deux cas de figure premier
cas de figure c'est il concerne eric
diard et jean louis bricout alors l'un
est de droite candidat dans les bouches
du rhône l'autre et de gauche candidat
dans l'aisne on ne peut pas faire plus
opposés sauf qu'ils ont un point commun
leur circonscription peut basculer au
rassemblement national dans les
bouches-du-rhône chez eric diard villa
ou bien marignane vitrolles marine le
pen a fait 58 % au second tour dans
celle de jean louis bricout 66% puis il
pourrait y avoir d épargner qu'est ce
que ça veut dire les épargner pour des
raisons politiques par la majorité alors
je vous donne deux exemples chez david
habib par exemple vice présidents
socialistes de l'assemblée bien la
majorité pourrait faire un geste et ne
pas mettre de candidat david habib il
n'a pas été investi par la nuque il est
très critique qu'on cet accord il est
dissidents soutenu par carole delga et
puis un autre cas très scrutées suite
damien abad c'est le président du groupe
l'est républicain ici à l'assemblée il
pourrait aussi obtenir la clémence de
l'assemblée pas de candidat en face
sonde acte d'allégeance à la majorité
ils sont très peu nombreux dans ce cas
là dans la majorité c'était soit ils
sont avec nous il soit contre nous
épargner pas de candidat en face voilà
ce qu'il faut comprendre merci merci
beaucoup elle à joseph on continue la
politique c'est jean castex qui fait ses
adieux ce soir à matignon en recevant
les collaborateurs vous limitiez un mot
sur notre premier ministre sur le départ
c'est à dieu comme vous y allez on prend
tous les risques parce que il est quand
même rare dans l'histoire de la vème
république qu'un premier ministre soit
autant retenu par la manche que par son
président enfin en tant que juif
politique entre j'ai jamais vu ça
regardez je crois que là franchement
et là on est pourtant
ccc tous plus est le plus grand dépit
pour pour castex de devoir est de voir
ne pas compter c'est en effet c'est à
dieu c'est à chaque fois sa dernière
séance à une sorte d'eddy mitchell 2
politique maintenant et alors que vous
l'avez très bien rappelé bien avant la
présidentielle il avait prévenu le
président de la république que il ne
souhaitait pas rester en place
jusqu'aux législatives en tout cas des
12 et 19 juin s'il était resté
d'ailleurs en place cela aura été aussi
une autre innovation d'ailleurs du
jamais vu sous la vème république alors
est ce que on peut dire maintenant
est-ce que l'heure du bilan est venue
alors oui le losc bilan est quand même
venu voilà permettent de le faire on
peut se permettre de le faire quand on
regarde la fiche wikipédia de jean
castex ce qui est intéressant c'est que
sa seule prise de position notable est
notée c'est son opposition à l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux alors c'est
quand même un peu ça peut paraître
paradoxal et même assez farce quand
certains macro nist même beaucoup de
maquereaux nist lui reprochent
précisément de rester dans l'ombre une
des propositions indépendants une
plaisanterie qui font souvent c'est une
voiture vide arrive devant matignon et
jean castex s'en sort donc voilà et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont la dent dure par
rapport au premier ministre il s'attaque
d'ailleurs même à son look 1 je cite
c'est celle indépendants qui lui qui
cite cette phrase à la campagne les
jambois qu'il est mal sapés comme eux et
ça plaît une phrase d'ailleurs qui au
passage soientt le mépris social vous
deux qui simule sémiologue mais
décidément en macro ni ce qui est sûr
c'est que jean castex sera toujours un
invité ou un étranger d'ailleurs il a
prévenu il n'est pas question de briller
pour lui un mandat de nationale 2
sénateurs même si les maires de peau de
prades pardon et il a refusé de rempiler
comme ministre sous l'autorité
partie relativement ministre de la mini
sont les vrais proposé d'être ministre
de la justice alors pour lui pas
question pardon d'être sais pas mais moi
ce jeu de mots d'être un sombre héros et
de faire ce genre de démarche sa
fidélité en fait si on le regarde bien
son parcours il réserve à nicolas
sarkozy d'ailleurs la seule fois où il a
pris vraiment des risques politiques
c'est lorsqu'il est sorti de sa réserve
pour soutenir nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il
est l'ancien chef de l'état lorsqu'il a
été condamné dans la sphère bygmalion
il dit en parlant de matignon je suis
sorti de l'enfer c'est dire c'est que à
tout prendre il préfère les deux ans
qu'il a passés à l'elysée auprès de
nicolas sarkozy que ces deux années bien
sûr à matignon à une exception près qui
va renforcer d'ailleurs son image
d'homme des terroirs de défenseurs des
terroirs c'est lorsqu'en septembre 2021
ils avaient inauguré l'aï posé la
première pierre de la relocalisation en
france de la production de paracétamol
s'était enlisé voilà vous remplirez car
en fait on retiendra de ce passage qui
peut paraître
anodin anecdotique qu'il est absolument
pas qui est même hautement symbolique
c'est que outre son côté couteau suisse
outre le fait qu' il a tenus le le
gouvernail incontestablement avec 10
période compliquée qui était la pandémie
et qui étaient les conséquences
immédiates de la guerre en ukraine en
fait il a la conviction que les temps
aujourd'hui nous oblige à la
souveraineté et cette souveraineté ne
pourra être faite que grâce que par en
passant par le volontarisme politique
est en fait ce qui frappe chez chez jean
castex et que un il n'a pas le souci des
modes et c'est heureux et qu'il a
totalement en fait assumer son côté
ancien monde et c'est heureux voilà vous
commencez à ces acides et puis vous
terminez plutôt élogieux pour ce premier
ministre sur sur le départ mariette
notre sémiologue vous vous êtes
intéressé au film de cédric klapisch
encore très beau film sur la danse
contemporaine notamment et vous y avait
vu une forme d'allégorie du corps social
français bah oui vous savez en un seul
mot pour dire corps le nôtre à notre
corps privée personnelle intime et puis
celui de la société on parle de corps
social et c'est pas anodin et je crois
que sans être un film politique encore
un très beau titre de de klapisch et
bien ce film nous donne une sorte de
parabole sur l'état de santé de notre
pays ah oui alors en bas précisément on
l'est on observe beaucoup un les colères
la dépression la maladie chronique du
chômage etc
en ce moment on parle même de fatigue
rowling démocratique lymphatique
démocratique or le film de klapisch et
le succès qu'il a passées comme un
million de de personnes l'ont vu en
quelques semaines nous disent exactement
le contraire avis c'est qu'ils y aillent
au contraire dans notre pays malgré les
blessures malgré les dépressions une
grande énergie mais il suffit de savoir
où aller l'a titillé pour qu'elles se
réveillent rappelle quand même peut-être
l'histoire c'est une danseuse d'opéra
une danseuse étoile qui se cassent la
cheville et qui est confronté à cette
question fondamentale va-t-elle pouvoir
continuer à danser ou doit-elle se
reconvertir voilà alors sans spolier la
fin ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'elle
trouve une troisième voie qui
extraordinaire parce qu'en fait elle
reste fidèle à sa vocation de reste
après avoir pensé qu'elle pouvait plus
être danseuse elle m'a quand même rester
danseuse mais elle change elle passe du
classique au contemporain et est tout à
fait de manière tout à fait différente
et c'est parce qu'elle fait d'autres
gestes avec son corps avec un autre
chorégraphe et bien qu'elle se soigne
son sa cheville qui devait opérer
finalement fonctionne alors j'y vois une
marianne dans cette jeune femme parce
que le marianne avait ce problème au
départ dans la dans le même temps dedans
l'égérie on peut trouver cette idée et
du coup je pense que ce film est un
conte de réparation il est il nous dit
que oui notre france allait blesser elle
à tous ces problèmes mais qu'elle
appliquait d'une certaine façon ce
message à notre pays exactement il faut
l'appliquer père s'il ya une analogie et
je crois que les politiques vont pas
dans le bon sens de l'analogie parce
qu'ils ne cessent de nous dire que tout
va mal et qu'il se pense comme des
médecins se penchant au chevet du pays
or là le pays leur montre à ses
politiques ses candidats à la députation
par exemple et bien que si lorsque on
montre avec optimisme et réalité vérité
les difficultés sans démagogie et bien
en ouvrant des perspectives au contraire
ça réveille une sorte de dents vie de
danser et de danser ensemble c'est très
important de collecter un film
absolument il ya toute une troupe s'est
offert chez ster le chorégraphe
israélien qui joue son propre rôle dans
le film il faut etc et il faut allez
devoir vous l'avez vu je vais les voir
ensemble un mot c'est que
en fait je le met en parallèle aussi un
film qui est sorti qui est et nord où là
aussi
l'enseignement avec michèle laroque et
ce qui est très intéressant en effet on
en parlait c'est que c'est ce type de
films sont vraiment des signes avant
coureurs voilà on fait ce qu'il vous
reste à faire aller au cinéma merci à
vous les affranchis très belle soirée
sur lcp pardon pour le retard et à
demain
[Musique]